CDC director Robert Redfield was a
witness at today's covid-19 hearing is
also a senior medical advisor at am LLC
a public health firm doctor it's always
good to have you with us thank you very
much for being here I just want to start
by playing this moment from
representative Jim Jordan about the back
and forth on this lab issue among the
top health officials in the United
States at a crucial time so three days
after they say it came from a lab they
changed their position and the only
intervening events a conference call
with Dr fauci and Dr Collins again a
call that Mr Redfield was not allowed to
be on the head of CDC and on the
coronavirus task force and then three
months later Shazam they get 9 million
bucks from Dr fauci
well I didn't act something
what is he referring to there and what's
your what's your take on that
well they obviously had a conversation
on February 1st and then I think several
after previously they had this group of
scientists had thought that the virus
did not look like it was a virus that
evolved in nature and then within three
to four days they changed their point of
view
the implication was they later received
substantial funding from NIH you know I
don't personally believe they're linked
but obviously it makes people wonder
that what was the basis for changing
their point of view within three days
there was no new science information
and I think what what bothers me about
it the most and I've said this before
that the approach they took was
antithetical to science I had made it
clear to Dr fauci and Jeremy Ferrar and
this in the
Spectros from The Who that I thought we
had to aggressively pursue both
hypotheses to spill over in the lab and
we had to use science to get at the
answer and I let them understand my own
thinking as a virologist that I thought
the evidence was definitely in favor of
a lab leak and again it was very
disappointing me to learn when the freed
of information came out months later
that they had had these calls and then I
was totally excluded from all of them
yeah I mean we were told time and time
again that if we were smart we'd be
listening to science and that science
was eventually essentially Dr fauci so
if you didn't go along with what he said
and he didn't believe everything he said
then you were against science which is
you know an insulting idea because
you're a scientist and your opinion was
being completely shut down how big
because there's so much focus and I
think rightfully so on how the lack of
transparency and the destruction of some
of the evidence that we believe China
did you know do you think in the early
days if they had been more open to this
idea that the virus looked like it had
been genetically engineered and very
similar to the kind of thing they were
working on in that lab do you think we
could have gotten closer to to the
origins and gotten more out of China in
those early days
yeah I don't think there's any question
I was in conversations with my
counterpart on New Year's Eve and the
first week of January offering to put a
team about 20 people in to help him
discern what was going on particularly
to learn whether there was evidence of
human to human transmission and
asymptomatic transmission both of which
he said there was neither human to human
transmission nor asymptomatic
transmission both of which were wrong it
was very unusual because in the past as
I had a CDC and him had a China CDC we
could just agree that I would come in
and help or he would come in and help
but he told me that he wasn't allowed to
give me permission I had to write a
request and which I did that request
unfortunately was never answered I did
ask the president to request that we
could come into president Z and he
didn't make those phone calls in the
first I think 10 days of January and
again the request was denied we were not
allowed in big mistake a big loss and
again I want to make a point point that
this this is not just China
this is basically the United States the
European scientist and China so when
people want to say well it's all China
no it was the United States scientific
Community it was the European scientific
ending and it was China all involved in
this research that I believe led to the
greatest pandemic of our time wow
it's extraordinary Story and there's a
lot to dig into here and we're going to
keep doing it Dr Redfield thank you I
want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now